in a suburban neighborhood in the city
of xi'an instructions from a loudspeaker
tell residents not to leave their
apartments unless absolutely necessary
three-year-old mangdo is making the most
of the opportunity to stretch his legs
members of his family are only allowed
outdoors to take covert 19 tests and
collect delivered supplies
they are among the 13 million people who
will spend new year's eve under strict
lockdown
my son is very young and doesn't
understand the lockdown or what the
increasing case numbers mean
he only knows that many people outside
are sick and if we go out we could be
infected
he panics a bit and feels scared
he tells me i don't want to be infected
and go into quarantine
his mother jung suwen is a kindergarten
teacher
she was shocked to receive notice of the
lockdown last week more than one
thousand cases have been reported in
xi'an since the beginning of december
it's the worst outbreak china has faced
in months and the most severe measures
empowered since the wuhan lockdown last
year a policy allowing one member of the
household to buy groceries every two
days was scrapped earlier this week
after infections continued to rise
some residents have taken to social
media to complain about a lack of access
to food and other essential goods
the complaints prompted authorities to
offer free food deliveries they say the
problem is with delivery and not supply
the supply of daily necessities in xi'an
is sufficient on the whole the commerce
ministry will take further measures to
ensure stable supply and prices of daily
necessities it's been two years since
who officials in china were first
notified of a mysterious flu-like
illness emerging in wuhan and two years
since dr lee wen liang sounded the alarm
about the outbreak before being silenced
and eventually dying from the
coronavirus himself
since then officials responsible for
mishandling information in the early
days of the pandemic have been punished
and most of the country's population has
been double vaccinated
but it's still unclear how the
coronavirus originated
china has defended its zero tolerance
approach to covet 19. officials here say
closed borders and heavy-handed measures
have kept total infections to about 100
000 and deaths to below 5 000 but
international experts have questioned
government figures
beijing is under increased pressure to
control this latest outbreak and lift
the xi'an lockdown before the winter
olympics open in february
for jung sewen and her son they have
little choice but to try to stay fit and
healthy at home
mango's favorite sport is swimming
but he doesn't know when he'll be able
to do it again for real
katrina you al jazeera beijing